Kellyanne Conway, seen here
leaving the American Girl
doll store
after a lightning bolt
brought her to life,
set the Internet aflame
this weekend.
She said White House Press
Secretary Sean Spicer's claim
that this was the most attended
inauguration in history
was not a lie,
but "an alternative fact."
Um, listen, guys, I'm only 19,
but I'm still old enough
to remember when
"alternative facts"
-were called lies.
-CATTA-PRETA: Lies.
Even Merriam-Webster Dictionary
told Conway to look it up.
Here it is. "A fact
is a piece of information
presented as having
objective reality."
-Oh, damn.
-(cheering, applause)
That's rough
when you get your ass
handed to you
by a dictionary. Uh...
Comedians, I would
like you to give me as many
alternative facts as you can
in 60 seconds,
and begin. Rich.
-Two plus two equals France.
-Points. Kevin.
Hitler was a black woman.
Points.
-NEALON: It's true.
-Jade.
Tupac is alive and we're dating.
All right, points.
Rich.
Dwayne Johnson is a stage name.
The Rock is his real name.
Yeah, points.
Kevin Nealon.
I can't imagine this diarrhea
came from a Cheesecake Factory.
Points.
NEALON:
I'm not... Yeah.
Jade.
Trump got his hands
surgically reduced
to make his penis look bigger.
All right, points. Yeah.
Kevin. Kevin Nealon.
I'm the host of this show.
-Oh, my God, that'd be amazing.
-Oh, my God.
-Take over.
-Holy (bleep).